germany is marking 30 years of the
country's reunification
on this 3rd of october germany's
national holiday
the country's president frankfurter
steinmeier gave a keynote speech at the
official ceremony in potsdam near berlin
an event that was significantly scaled
down due to the coronavirus pandemic
a landmark date celebrating 30 years
since the divided germany became one
again
the babelsberg film studios in potsdam
just outside berlin
provided the stage for the official
ceremony
a toned-down event due to the
coronavirus pandemic
only 230 guests were present about
one-fifth of the audience originally
planned plans for a big street party
have to be abandoned
in his keynote speech german president
frank walter steinmeier said the
pandemic couldn't blunt the country's
pride
in the achievement of reunification he
paid tribute to the peaceful revolution
in communist east germany that brought
down the berlin wall
in november 1989.
in 2020 the german federal republic is a
country that has been molded
by east germans and west germans well
rooted families and migrants
it is a country that draws hope from the
victory of the ideas
of 1989. the two
many were the lessons learned from
germany's division and reunification
steinmaya said
including the country's strong belief in
international cooperation
an approach now often being called into
question around the world
we germans are committed to
international cooperation
even though it has become harder
especially since it has become harder
we want to stand up for a strong and
fair international order
together with our partners in europe
ladies and gentlemen dear guests
this too is a lesson and mission we've
inherited from our history
a day of remembrance but also of
celebration
accompanied by performances appealing to
the musical tastes of all age groups
including the almost 13 million germans
who are 30 years old or younger
who never experienced a divided germany
a country now united but where economic
and sometimes cultural differences still
exist
recent polls show two-thirds of germans
don't think the process of reunification
is complete
a task that will be up to younger
generations to accomplish in the years
to come
now let's bring in our correspondence
nina harza and potsdam and
thomas sparrow in berlin who have been
covering uh events today nina let's
start with you you've been following
president steinmeier's address
what's your take on what he said
well i thought it was a very good speech
it was very long and
president steinmeier stressed the fact
that we mustn't forget that it was a
peaceful revolution that
ultimately led to german unification
that
first brought down the berlin wall in
1989 and then helped
bring down the gdr the socialist
dictatorship as some call it and he said
of course there are still differences
there between east and west but what we
mustn't forget
is that the spirit of this peaceful
revolution is something that we need to
remember when we look at what's going on
in the world and that people want
freedom and democracy around the world
and that they're willing to sacrifice a
lot for it
and there are p people here in germany
that's what president steinmeier also
said
who are beginning to question that very
system of democracy and that they must
do everything
against those groups he was uh
quite directly referring uh to a rise in
ripening populism recently
uh we've prepared prepared a sound bite
there let's listen in
vegas how ignorant of historical fact
must those be
who would raise the black white and red
flag of the german empire of 1871
or even the battle flag in front of the
democratically elected
parliament
they're part of a tradition that doesn't
stand for our republic
or our democracy no today we stand
firmly on the bedrock of a struggle for
freedom
and a history of democracy
president steinmeier there criticizing
those waving imperial german flags in
front of the german parliament recently
thomas can you give us some background
on this
well those who were actually waving
those flags in front of the german
parliament a few weeks ago
many of them belonged to a group called
the reichsburg and the iceberg are
actually
against the german state they don't
believe even in the existence of the
german
state we saw a couple of people here a
very small group of people here at the
brandenburg gate today also waving
some of those imperial flags having
t-shirts wearing t-shirts with
conspiracy theories so they were also
probably at the
protests a few weeks ago here in in
berlin
there are other protests here in in the
brandenburg gate
today as well including uh very loud you
can probably
hear them a group of communists from
latin america that are very skeptical of
german unity and are in favor of the gdr
of the german democratic republic uh so
you can clearly see that there's a
different groups of people here in in
berlin normally this is the place where
german unity is celebrated but because
of the coronavirus pandemic
celebrations here in berlin were
cancelled
thomas 30 years after reunification
these protests are
also a sign of differences big
differences that still exist between
east and west germany
there are signs of different views on
democracy of different views on the
german
unity there's not only one narrative
about what happened
30 years ago and about how this has
developed in the last
three decades and it is important also
to stress these differences between east
and west there are differences for
example when it comes to wages when it
comes to unemployment that mostly affect
people
in the east but it's also important to
stress that three decades after german
reunification
germany has indeed progressed a lot
germany has indeed become
a very stable prosperous country at the
heart of europe and that's something
that german political leaders are very
proud about
uh let's come back to you nina you're in
potsdam where the central event was
being held earlier today what else is
planned for today
well of course thomas mentioned it the
official festivities have all been
scaled down they've been cancelled in
berlin altogether but
potsdam here has installed a big
alley where all the individual federal
states have a chance to present
themselves
in cubes i hope you can see them behind
me in the background and so people are
strolling by
and just learning about each other
essentially learning about other
regions in germany then there will be
more festivities going on at a central
square here in potsdam and at
seven o'clock german time the whole
country is supposed to sing together
this
is something which is going to happen
remotely but the main event is going to
take place in leipzig of course a very
important
place when you look at the peaceful
revolution that led to german
unification ultimately
and so the whole country can join in
virtually
as we do everything virtually most
things
virtually these days during the
coronavirus pandemic
nina has in potsdam and thomas sparrow
in berlin
thank you both
you